this way
[Music]
demonstrators who had been gathering at
the capitol and
marched there today breached the capitol
building
hundreds of protesters our reporters on
on the scene tell us you know it could
be seen
they were pushing back police people
were waving trump flags
thousands probably could be you know
surrounded the building
climbing up walls we're seeing you know
people inside the building
the house and the senate were in session
when this happened protesters are in the
building thank you
without objection the house is going to
go back into recess
they broke the glass everybody stayed
down
we were just told that there has been
tear gas
in the rotunda and we're being
instructed
to each of us get gas masks that are
under our seats
it is a really unprecedented situation
which
you know follows months of the president
questioning contesting and rejecting the
election results uh
you know filing numerous lawsuits that
have been
rejected in the courts uh you know
calling for investigations
there has been no evidence that has come
forth that has
uh you know backed up his claims his you
know until recently
attorney general uh william barr said he
they had not found any evidence of
widespread voter fraud that would
overturn the election results
you know tens of lawsuits have been
thrown out
but the president has continued to
insist this and at a
rally earlier today near the white house
he encouraged his supporters to march to
the capitol and
put pressure on congress to overturn
president-elect biden's win
[Music]
let me be very clear the scenes of chaos
at the capitol
do not reflect a true america
do not represent who we are it's
chaos it borders on sedition
and it must end now i call on this mob
to pull back and allow the work of
democracy to go
forward i know your pain i know you're
hurt we had an election
this was a fraudulent election but we
can't
play into the hands of these people
we have to have peace so go home
we love you you're very special you've
seen what happens
you see the way others are treated that
are so bad and so evil
i know how you feel but go home and go
home at peace
the senate will come to order
the vice president as president of the
senate would like to give a brief
statement
with the indulgence of the senators
today was a dark day in the history of
the united states capital
but thanks to the swift efforts of u.s
capitol police
federal state and local law enforcement
the violence was quelled the capital is
secured
and the people's work continues